wir verlassen die Soap zur richtigen
Herz das finde ich gut weil es nämlich
außerordentlich viele Menschen gibt
mehrere Millionen viele Millionen
vielleicht sogar in Deutschland die
haben jetzt echter Existenzsorgen und
das betrifft jetzt nicht nur Leute
vielleicht im Hartz IV Bezug sondern das
betrifft auch sehr viel in der
Mittelschicht Deutschland hat sich immer
dadurch ausgezeichnet durch den
Mittelstand eine Wirtschaftsform zu
pflegen die eine breite Mittelschicht
ermöglicht hat anders als in anderen
europäischen Ländern dadurch war ja auch
immer sehr viel Frieden die Franzosen
sind viel schneller auf der Straße als
die Deutschen dafür gibt's Gründe auch
in dem sozialen Bereich da gibt es
interessante Bücher wie äh äh Peripherie
oder so da kann man das Lesen aber der
entscheidende Punkt ist dass diese
Regierung und da kann ich auch die FDP
nicht ausnehmen
dass diese Regierung sich nicht
öffentlich sich nicht öffentlich zum
Industriestandort Deutschland kennt das
viele die in der Regierung agieren bis
hin ins Wirtschaftsministerium nach
meinem Dafürhalten zu wenig
wirtschaftlichen und finanzfrischen
Sachverstand erkennen lassen dass die
Unternehmer maximal verunsichert sind
das ist aber weil diese agilen zwei bis
drei Millionen sozusagen die Leute
beschäftigen und Lohn und Brot bringen
sind eigentlich das Schwungrad unserer
Gesellschaft und wenn die überlegen ob
sie noch Investitionen machen wenn wir
überlegen ob sie ihre Bude zum ersten
ersten zumachen müssen wegen der
Energiepreise wenn sie überlegen dass
große Investitionen von ausländischen
Investoren nicht mehr stattfinden weil
man Deutschland und Europa nicht mehr
anpeilt sondern lieber nach China geht
nach Abu Dhabi oder in die USA dann
haben wir einen veritables Problem denn
die Deutschen sind nicht per se Reich
wir haben auch nicht genug Rohstoffe die
wie die Russen dann weltweit verkaufen
können zu guten Geld sondern wir müssen
Produkte veredeln das setzt eine
unglaubliche Tiefe in der Technologie
und in der Fertigung voraus und wenn wir
diese Prozesse stören auch durch Fehlern
der Politik die gravierend sind ein
halbes Jahr lang nicht zu reagieren nach
dem Ausbruch des Krieges in der
Energiefrage ist ein verdammtes
Versäumnis und hat jetzt zu den
Problemen geführt die man haben wir
haben zu Höchstpreisen jetzt die
Gasspeicher gefüllt und wenigstens diese
Sicherheit herzustellen aber das sind 25
Prozent unseres jahresbedarfes und
hatten man leichten Oktober und leicht
November aber das wird sich alles ändern
und wir haben einen veritables Problem
mit der Wirtschaft die ist jetzt unter
voraus vor Herausforderungen gesetzt die
wir vorher nicht hatten Corona waren
Testfall da ist aber um die
Dienstleister gegangen wir reden jetzt
vom industriellen Herzen dieses Landes
und ich erwarte einfach dass alle Kräfte
konzentriert werden darauf die
industrielle Substanz dieses Landes zu
halten und damit im Prinzip unseren
Kapitalstock als Bundesrepublik
Deutschland stabil zu halten das auch
für die Europäer wichtig wenn wir
versagen ist ganz Europa betroffen aber
wenn ich das einmal zusammenfassen waren
also vor der die Industrialisierung
dieses Landes ja ob sie nun absichtlich
passiert ist passiert aber was wäre dann
die Lösung der Regierungswechsel naja
also meine mein Vorschlag ist wir
brauchen eine Regierung der nationalen
Verantwortung und der Vernunft das
können auch die jetzt agierenden
Parteien sein wenn sie Vernunft annehmen
und ich kann nicht nachvollziehen dass
wir uns riesigen unter Stromversorgung
an als Bein binden wenn wir weiter
laufen lassen könnten die sechs AKWs
oder wenn wir in der Kohle vielleicht
noch mal überlegen mit CCS zu arbeiten
wenn es da also das Karten capture wenn
es darum geht dass man Kohlendioxid aus
der Atmosphäre raushält gibt es
Techniken auch die Kohle anders zu
gestalten und das zu machen und
Atomkraft ist sowieso bei den ganzen
Umweltschützern außerhalb Deutschlands
anerkannte ökotechnik also was soll der
Quark wir riskieren ja auch die
Wirtschaft der anderen Nachbarländer
da rennen sie bei der FDP sicherlich
offene Türen ein wir müssen allerdings
feststellen dass nachdem die Ampel die
Regierung übernommen hat wir unabhängig
von dem Krieg Russland gegen die Ukraine
einfach eine ganze Menge Defizite geerbt
haben also das Thema verkaufte
Energiewende ist eine originäres Thema
von der großen Koalition von der CDU das
Thema das nicht in Zukunft Technologien
in der im Land investiert wurde ist ein
originäres Thema was die CDU mit Frau
Merkel vorneweg zu beantworten hat dass
wir in der Sicherheitspolitik nicht
vorangekommen sind dass die Bundeswehr
kaputt gespart sind sind alles Themen
die am Ende des Tages mit der CDU nach
Hause gehen und jetzt haben wir in der
Tat die Situation dass wir da haben bin
ich vollkommen bei Ihnen die
industriellen Kerne unseres Landes
sichern müssen deswegen müssen wir über
die gasbremse reden wir müssen über die
strompreisbremse reden das hätte
schneller gehen können richtig wobei
auch das muss man der Fairness halber
sagen dass im Juni Juli die Situation
noch die war dass die Gaspreise nicht so
exorbitant hoch waren das soll jetzt
nicht verteidigen dass wir die
gaspreisbremse noch nicht auf dem Weg
gebracht haben das bmwk arbeitet noch
dran das Wirtschaftsministerium und wir
hoffen dass der Weg jetzt bald eine
Vorlage ins Kabinett macht aber ich
glaube schon dass der Fokus auch dieser
Regierung darauf ist dass Arbeitsplätze
in diesem Land gesichert werden sonst
würden wir ja nicht mehrere hundert
Milliarden Euro ausgeben um das
sicherzustellen vorstellen aber wenn
Energie aus Russland nicht mehr zur
Verfügung steht dann kann man nicht von
heute auf morgen andere Energiequellen
erschließen daran arbeiten wir jetzt mit
Hochdruck und die Versäumnisse die die
einheitig in der einseitigen
Abhängigkeit von russischen pipeline-gas
geschaffen wurden sind auch ein Thema
was die große Koalition in den letzten
Jahren zu fassen
wenn es so wäre dass man genug getan
hätte er nicht getan also nichts getan
hätte dann wären den Ländern ja jetzt
was weiter wir haben verschiedene
Regierungen in den Bundesländern es gibt
sogar eins von dem grünen
Ministerpräsidenten regiert wird dann
müssten die ja schon weiter sein man hat
sich immer auf Strom fokussiert man hat
fünf vier Fünftel das Energiemarktes
nicht betrachtet man hat sich nicht auf
Speichertechnologie konzentriert man
kann ja viel diskutieren aber es ist ja
auch in den Bundesländern nicht wirklich
wesentliches passiert zumindest in den
meisten nicht und die Frage die sich mir
stellt ist diese Energiewende wie sie
konzipiert wurde noch unter
Berücksichtigung auch von mir aus der
russischen Gaslieferungen ist
ineffizient überteuert sie funktioniert
nicht wir schalten funktionierende
Stromversorgung ab für Stromversorgung
die nicht funktioniert das ist nicht
hinnehmbar das ist ein Industrieland
kein Agrarstaat also das ist doch alles
schadensbegrenzt das ist ja das krasse
und das ist ja das was ich in der
Politik ist stört ja also seit Jahren
schon ist alles nur
schadensbegrenzungspolitik es wir haben
eine Krise was ist eine Krise eine Krise
ist ein Symptom eines Zustands und die
ganze Zeit beschäftigen uns mit Krisen
und es wird uns als Erfolg verkauft dass
man irgendwas dabei improvisiert das
irgendwie dann irgendwie das ein
bisschen rettet aber eine Krise aus der
Krise muss man lernen ja man muss die
Krise lösen oder und dann guckt man sich
woraus entstehen eigentlich diese ganzen
Krisen und dann das passiert halt nicht
weil dann schon wieder die nächste Krise
kommt aber wobei man sagen muss das ist
unterschiedliche Art von Krisen gibt
also die wenn wenn ein Land wie Russland
einen Krieg anzettelt und dann ähm
freies Land überfällt dann ist das eine
Krise die war jetzt nicht unbedingt
voraus aber das was Frau Hermenau ja
beschreibt ist eine Krise die sich ja
schon seit Jahren abzeichnet wenn man
nach Baden-Württemberg schaut und Herr
Meier sie haben das schon versucht alles
der CDU zuzuschieben ich erinnere mich
dass der zweite Atomausstieg unter einer
schwarz-gelben Regierung passiert ist
dann ist mein Eindruck gewesen dass in
den letzten 16 Jahren Angela Merkel
immerhin in 12 Jahren die
spd-koalitionspartner Waren der letzte
Vizekanzler ist jetzt Bundeskanzler der
hat alles mitgetragen und wenn ich das
richtig sehe dann sind auch die Grünen
in ganz ganz vielen Bundesländern mit
einer Regierung bzw in Baden
ohne Kollegen Windräder in
Baden-Württemberg aufgestellt werden
dann ist das Ganze Schreien der Grünen
ähm ein Schrein wirklich in dem Fall
gegen den Wind es ist ein verlogenes
schreien weil die Grünen selbst nicht in
der Lage sind die Energiewende die sie
wollen so zu treiben wie es nötig wäre
wenn man es denn so wollte aber der
Punkt den vorher noch macht den Einsatz
den sag ich noch oder sind zwei ist ja
dass wir hier äh ein Wirtschaftsstandort
quasi
sukzessive schreddern indem wir das
Kernkapital was wir haben nämlich
günstige und den großen Teil noch
unabhängige Energie dass wir uns dieses
Vorteiles berauben und wenn man in der
Koalition sich in Berlin umhört er auch
in ihrer Partei und mit Politikerinnen
und Politikern spricht über die Frage
was ist denn eigentlich wenn das
Ökostrom Ziel 80% im Jahr 20 30/32 nicht
erreicht wird was passiert
ist es muss erreichbar werden
kommen wir doch ein bisschen noch mal
also zum einen wir haben Krisen wir
haben letztlich zwei schwarze Schwäne
mit Corona und mit dem äh dem Krieg in
der Ukraine oder Pandemie selbst vorbei
richtig glücklicherweise aber wir hatten
jetzt drei Jahre im Ausnahmezustand so
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir uns
in der Zeit angucken müssen was davor an
Vorbereitung falsch gelaufen ist wir
müssen in der konkreten Krise zunächst
erstmal löschen das tut diese
Bundesregierung mit viel Geld da kann
man darüber diskutieren ob das effizient
alles eingesetzt wird und dann muss man
anschließend die leeren rausziehen und
das kann keine leere sein zu sagen es
muss funktionieren sondern am Ende das
hat Christian Linda auch gesagt haben
wie gesagt wir müssen über Schiefer
Gasförderung sprechen wir müssen darüber
reden dass wir heimische fossile
Energieträger wieder fördern das kann
nicht sein dass die ganze Zeit aus
Amerika LG Gas einführen was über der
Fördermethoden gewonnen wird was wir in
Deutschland nicht haben wollen und wir
müssen uns ehrlich machen es
bisher kein gesellschaftlichen Konsens
die Atomkraftwerke länger laufen zu
lassen Herr Söder hat aber das hat sich
doch Bevölkerung geändert Herr Söder hat
noch gesagt wenn bis Ende 22 die
Atomkraftwerke nicht abgeschaltet werden
den tritt ja zurück so also deswegen
muss man ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe
nicht viele Leute würden gestern
bei Politiker reden dass wir eine ganz
schnell Zwischenfrage stellen mir fällt
das immer wieder auf bei Politikern
dieser Runde da müssen wir uns ehrlich
machen das heißt wir haben sonst meine
unehrliche Politik gehabt am Ende muss
es darum dass diejenigen die sich
vielleicht geirrt haben die vielleicht
ein Stück weit auch Lebenslügen
hinterher gerannt sind bereits sind zu
akzeptieren dass sie sich gehört haben
und das ist eine das Thema hatten wir
eben in nach meiner Einschätzung in
weiten Teilen natürlich auch die grüne
Politik die uns in diesem in diese
Energiewende in den Nullerjahren quasi
so vorangebracht hat dass der
Bundesrechnungshof schon vor vier fünf
Jahren gesagt hat nirgendwo wie in
Deutschland ist die Energiewende so
teuer und so effizient umgesetzt worden
genau diese Eingeständnisse sind ja sehr
nett aber Frau Hermenau wenn ich Sie
richtig verstanden habe sie wollen ja
Taten sehen und nicht immer nur ehrlich
fragen doch wir brauchen einen großen
Piraten mehr ich will auch nicht mehr
täglich den Lernfortschritt
irgendwelcher Minister nachverfolgen
müssen das ist mir eigentlich zu
intellektuell zu wenig ja ich möchte
gerne dass wir ein klares Bekenntnis zum
Industriestandort haben das bedeutet
dass man nicht Flickschusterei betreibt
an Symptomen im Moment sondern das
bedeutet dass man sagt wir setzen die
Energiewende jetzt einfach mal drei vier
Jahre oder 5 Jahre alt wollen Sie eine
neue Regierung oder nicht neu sein die
muss neu Arbeiten verstehen Sie also es
kann auch gerne sein dass der Olaf
Scholz in den sauren Apfel beißt und dem
Friedrich schmerzvorschläge kommen wir
machen eine große Koalition der Vernunft
und der Friedrich Schmerz beißen dafür
müsste es ja nur weil der Friedrich
Schmerz beißen den anderen sauren Apfel
und sagt naja gut dann werde ich halt
nicht mehr Kanzler wenn beide Männer das
ertragen was ja eine Frage ist die man
stellen darf
Moment wäre ja die Frage dass man dann
einen größeren Pool anläutert hat wo man
noch mal neu denken
weil ich Strauß ihm zu weil wir sind in
einer so der Solaranlage dass die
ausländischen Investoren um Deutschland
inzwischen einen Bogen machen es geht
nicht mehr darum ob wir bis zum Ostern
keinen Blackout gehabt haben das ist
nicht mehr die Frage die Frage ist ob
Deutschland noch als Industriestandort
auch außerhalb Deutschlands wahrgenommen
wird und da hat die Bundesregierung eine
Pflicht zu tun ich fand interessant das
Herr Scholz nach China geflogen ist für
zwei Stunden auch Jens und mit über 16
Milliarden Euro Auftrag wieder kam für
Airbus und damit die Amerikaner und
beruhigen Manuel hat das fand ich
schlaue Sache und so muss das eigentlich
laufen hat keiner darüber gesprochen
aber das ist wichtig so und diese Sache
müssen sich die Regierung stellen und
wenn sie jetzige Koalition nicht kann
weil ein oder zwei oder drei Leute
einfach ein bisschen auf ihre
Programmierung Fixierung drauf sind dann
tut es mir leid dann müssen wir eben
eine andere Zusammensetzung der
Regierung nehmen hauptsache die Leute
machen das was nötig ist aber das werden
sie nicht machen wenn die SPD sagt sie
möchte ist nicht die CDU sagt sie möchte
sich dann ist das quasi genau derselbe
Vorhof den sie 80 Millionen Deutschen
die sagen am Ende am Ende haben wir
Wahlen durchgeführt im letzten Jahr
haben danach eine Koalition gebildet es
war so dass die CDU
nicht koalieren wollte oder konnte zu
damaligen Zeit ich hätte mir auch
gewünscht dass wir eher in Jamaika
Konstellation wirklich gewünscht ich
glaube schon
dass er nicht reden wollen würde das
Problem war ja das zum einen auch daher
Söder gesagt hat wir gehen in die
Opposition zum anderen war es so dass in
den Sondierungsgesprächen die wir hatten
die
die Vertraulichkeit nicht hergestellt
war weil ständig gerade auch Richtung
Bild-Zeitung aus den Sitzungen eins zu
eins offensichtlich aus der
unionsperspektive raus ähm
informiert kann man sehen aber man
braucht ja eine Grundlage für eine
vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit und die
war einfach nicht da wichtiger als das
Programm also ehrlich gesagt mich würde
jetzt weniger interessieren ob irgendwer
Nachrichten rausschickt als sie am Ende
das Programm in den letzten Jahr war
dass wir eine jamaika-konstellation
nicht hinbekommen haben und zu
Demokratie und Wahlen gehört das
anschließend Parteien Kompromisse machen
müssen in einem Koalitionsvertrag und
versuchen müssen dann mit diesen
Kompromissen aus ihrer jeweiligen
Programmatik das Beste für das Land zu
gestalten wir haben jetzt in diesem Jahr
besondere Herausforderungen wir haben
alle nicht gesehen was ab Februar hier
an Belastung sowohl in einer
Sicherheitspolitik als auch in den
Energiepolitik auf uns zukam und jetzt
sind wir im notbetrieben der größte
Fehler den Robert habe bisher gemacht
ne ich glaube
ich glaube dass
habe ich schneller in der Tat oder die
ganze
Bundesregierung schneller hätte das
Thema Gaspreis Bremse auf den Weg
bringen müssen natürlich bin ich der
Auffassung das haben wir gesagt dass wir
das Thema Kernenergie länger hätten
fahren
das wäre gut aber auf der anderen Seite
müssen wir auch da realistisch sein wir
reden ja also am Ende geht es ja nicht
nur darum theoretisch irgendwas zu
fordern es geht darum ob es eine
realistische
umsetzungswahrscheinlichkeit gibt und
nachdem der Bundeskanzler hier ein
Machtwort gesprochen hat nachdem wir die
einzige sind in dieser
Koalition die sagen wir wollen die
Atomkraftwerke länger laufen lassen als
bis April nächsten Jahres muss man
irgendwann akzeptieren dass der Drops
Beispiel
sagen am Ende des Tages ist dafür
momentan keine politische Mehrheit da
und das muss man akzeptieren ich finde
es interessanter
dass wir jetzt zunächst erstmal darüber
reden ich sagtest dass wir über über
konventionelle Gasförderung in
Deutschland reden dass wir über skiver
Gasförderung
es passiert
23 auf den Winter 23 4 schauen sagt eine
Wirtschaftspartei wie die FDP ja ist
jetzt mit grünen ich würde hier gerne
einmal wir müssen auch da ehrlich sein
nur weil wir drei Atomkraftwerke länger
laufen lassen werden wir nicht wir
werden eine Strompreis Entlastung haben
deswegen wollen wir es ja deswegen ist
es wichtig aber die Probleme die wir im
Winter 23 24 bekommen können wenn wir in
kalten Winter jetzt in diesem Jahr
bekommen werden wir nicht allein durch
das länger laufen lassen
20 Millionen haushalteversorgung mit
Strom
in Deutschland und das muss auch gemacht
werden gerne mal eine Frage an Michael
nass stellen hier in der Runde
Gesichte
Frage ist jetzt hat es Herr Meier denn
geschafft sie können jetzt eigentlich
fdp-bilder werden oder grün sind sie eh
nicht mehr ganz so befreundet und jetzt
nach diesem Plädoyer für die Politik
nein ich wie gesagt
gerade mit der mit dem Politikern die
nicht agieren es geht nur noch irgendwie
Reaktionen und auch das hier auch es
geht doch nicht darum also was sie hier
gerade gesagt haben mit den
Atomkraftwerke 20 Millionen weiter wir
müssen vielleicht mal einen Schritt
zurückgehen und ich gucke mir vielleicht
nicht sein dass die Schriftsteller bin
oder so ich gucke mir eher den ich gucke
ja in Beschäftigung mit der mich mit der
Psyche oder mit dem Menschen ja und wir
beschäftigen uns in der Runde eigentlich
nur mit der Wirtschaft und welches ist
das das Problem auch also ich habe auch
den Eindruck dass
die Politiker in der heutigen Zeit
eher auf das reibungslose Funktionieren
der Wirtschaft Wert legen als auf den
Menschen zu gucken denn wir führen ja
ein Leben schauen Sie den auch auf die
Menschen die die Gasrechnung nicht mehr
bezahlen können die Angst vor dem
glasrechnungen haben genau da werden wir
noch drauf kommen ich wollte nur sagen
warum ja wirklich wichtig ist dass wir
jetzt die Kurve kriegen
es wird in geostrategischen
Veränderungen ist jetzt jeder muss
großartig überlegen in der
großwirtschaft wo er investiert ich habe
das vorhin bloß kurz angedeutet in
Europa und vor allen Dingen Deutschland
als ein potenzieller
Investitionsstandort von der Karte
genommen wird wenn die mehrere Optionen
haben haben wir mittelfristig ein
dramatisches Problem dass sofort soziale
Probleme hervorruft weil die Leute keine
hohen Gehälter mehr bekommen es gibt
Entlassungen wir können jetzt mal nur in
die autobanische gucken auch andere da
war vorher schon der Wurm drin vor dem
Krieg mit den Russen und den Ukrainern
ich denke es ist entscheidend aus meiner
Sicht dass die Regierung jetzt sehr
schnell in wenigen Wochen noch vor
Jahresende dazu übergeht deutlich zu
machen dass die Absicht besteht dass
Deutschland ein industriestand dort
bleibt und das dafür weil die Realitäten
sich
selbstständiger sprechen völlig geändert
die Regierung erkennt die Veränderung
der Realitäten an und passt ihre
Programmatik an das ist entscheidend in
meinen Augen also sie fordern neuen
Koalitionsvertrag ja natürlich wenn die
Koalition das schafft kann sie auch von
mir aus weitere gehen sie muss aber die
Realitäten abbilden